well thank you very much for having me
today
this is really cool I I did really want
to thank Tom he has asked me to speak in
a number of his classes and the
curriculums that he has put together
just incredible and the Mayfield Fellows
Program he is correct so when we started
octave a year and a half ago we got our
Series A funding year and a half ago
there were three of us and we were able
to get two of the twelve Mayfield
Fellows so they got to do some
incredible work for us but they also had
a profound effect on our culture going
forward there you can still see things
so Maurice Chang is here might be such
is in China try not to get the
coronavirus right now and then last
summer we had Julia Schultz and she was
able to build a whole knowledge base
engine for us so real things that have
will play out in our company so thank
you Tom for that thank you for you guys
for helping out what I thought I would
talk about today my agenda is about
confidence and I'll talk about what that
means to me why it's important in an
entrepreneurial venture how to get it
and how to keep it you'll learn a little
bit about my entrepreneurial journey on
the way and then I'll have time for
question and answer that sound like a
plan great thank you okay let's warm up
with just a little fun fact I grew up in
Palo Alto I went to Walter Hayes
elementary on a barker Darrow Road I
went to castilleja
on Embarcadero Road I went to Palo Alto
High School on Embarcadero Road and if
you know anything about Embarcadero Road
it dead-ends into Stanford if I had gone
to Stanford I would have done all my
education on one Street I did not I
veered off and I went to Cal please
don't hold that against me but that is
where I am from now back to confidence
so I'm not talking about the kind of
hubris the confidence that the head that
Silicon Valley venture firms are getting
a lot of press about these days I'm
talking about the confidence that comes
from your gut
from really knowing yourself and knowing
your craft knowing your function your
job your subject matter so that you are
it's a foundation that you can build on
that kind of confidence so one of my few
charts all due today so learning about
yourself and learning about your craft
hopefully the curve is something like
this where you learn more over time and
at an increasing rate small problem most
of the important decisions really
important decisions you have to make in
life
what's my career gonna be and I gotta
get married have a life partner children
so a lot of you are engineers what can
you do you can either try and come up
the curve faster or you can push out the
decisions I did a little books
all right so how why is confidence this
kind of confidence where you know
yourself and you know your craft why is
that particularly important to an
entrepreneur well first of all you're
saying you've come up with a solution to
a problem that a lot of people have
confident and here's the key they're
going to pay for it so you've found a
solution to a problem a lot of people
have and you're confident they're gonna
pay for it that that takes a little
something and that these are riskier
ventures people seem to think but I
think if you have that kind of
confidence perhaps you don't see it as
risky my first entrepreneurial venture
I left a large company and I started I
knew I needed to leave that company and
I started networking going to event
trying to build a a network of
entrepreneurial colleagues and I must
have gone to some event where I met
Brian Robertson Venrock
and a couple of months later he sent me
an email and he said
and he copied Mustapha Rinaldi who is
now the CTO of alumina and he said you
should - you two should meet
entire text of the email mustafa wrote
back how about Wednesday at 3:00 entire
text to the email I responded great and
I assume at the place on your signature
block which was the Stanford genome
Technology Center showed up seven guys
sitting in a room with a laptop they
went through their pitch asked me if I
wanted to help them and I had the
confidence from having built an
organization from eight people to 85
people about one third of the company
that by the time I left that was world
class I'd had a tremendous mentor in
Bruce Lee's and I felt I was confident I
could do this I could scale an
organization and that's what they were
asking me to do so as a entrepreneur you
need to have the confidence to start the
company get involved in the company but
then you need the confidence to
persevere right you're gonna if you're
trying to do something new and
innovative there's not going to be a
clear roadmap my company now octave
bioscience as Tom described it we're
trying to do a pretty complex thing and
in fact we have four different things
we're doing each one could be their own
company so not only are we trying to
stand up for companies at the same time
but we're trying to coordinate them it's
very complex it's in healthcare makes it
even more challenging so there are
moments where we're trying to figure
something out and the road ahead
not so much roadblocks but say foggy
maybe whiteout conditions we just don't
quite know what to do or how to move
forward but my business partner in this
bill Hagstrom and I have had enough
experience that we know you just have to
keep moving forward with a startup you
don't have the choice to quit or stop
you have to figure it out and we have
the confidence from our past experiences
of working hard to learn our craft to
know we will work it out and we have
hired this incredible team who we will
come through the fog into the Promised
Land and the things they've innovated on
every day it's better than I could have
even hoped it's just an incredible team
what's going on it's magical so you need
to have confidence to take the risk to
start the company to persevere and you
need it to make the hard decisions one
of the hardest decisions is hiring you
will hear everybody talk about how the
teams are most important people are
everything you need to hire rock stars
ace hire IASB Hut's Abbie's higher C's
but I'm not sure that most people
actually do that and where they fall
down is you have a deadline
you've been interviewing for a long time
your people are tired of covering for
that position so you start to think good
enough is good enough and I think if you
talk to people from any one of my past
companies one of the things they
remember most about what I brought to
that is I will not lower the bar I have
never found I'm confident I have never
found that any deadline any conference
any anything is worth not taking a few
more months to find the right person
who's really a rock star because over
time if you hire good enough alright
then in the next five years they will
probably miss deadlines they will
probably bring the rest of the team down
so I really hold that bar high and I get
a lot of pushback people are pretty
uncomfortable with that and all I have
to do is say look around the room you
all cleared that bar and then they see
all the things that they're able to do
together so you need the confidence to
start the company to persevere to make
the hard decisions but almost most
importantly you need the confidence in
knowing yourself and knowing your craft
so you're you have this foundation you
can be quiet
inside
you don't have anything you need to feel
you have to prove so you can hear others
you can go into a meeting you can go
into a situation and be open and listen
to what other people can bring to the
situation and you will find that you
will be much more innovative in your
solutions so confidence to start the
company confidence to persevere
confidence to make the hard decisions
and the confidence so that you can hear
others so if I've made the case that you
need confidence and an entrepreneurial
venture how do you get it Tom talked
about how is this inaugural entrepreneur
in residence for New York City for which
I believe I should have gotten a tiara
it's that kind of title none' showed up
I've moved on
in that job I was supposed to stitch
together the life science I'm a stem
girl love math and science the
entrepreneurial ecosystem in New York
City and try and build it up they had
some tech stuff going on but not a lot
on the medical side and so I would meet
with entrepreneurs every day and help
them think through their strategy and
funding I was asked to write a blog at
the time and I thought what can I add to
the conversation what can I write about
that nobody else is writing about and I
found that a lot of the blogs would talk
strategically about what you need to do
but they weren't giving tactical advice
what could a first-time entrepreneur do
so I presented you with this strategic
idea you need to have confidence you
need to learn your about yourself you
need to learn about your craft how do
you go about doing that the first thing
is everything is a learning situation so
you need to pay attention and you need
to be introspective when I went to Cal I
was on the women's crew team I got to
Cal I'd never even heard of crew the
crew coach came up to me and said do you
want to be on the crew team I said
what's that he said rowing and I'm like
rowing it's horrible and he so I said no
thank you
but people came up to me all week long
every line I stood and asked me to be on
the crew team so I said I'll go to your
orientation and I fell in love with it I
don't know how much you know about
rowing but long skinny boat eight people
in it you go this direction but you face
that direction and it's the ultimate
team sport you have to be able to
everybody has one or you have to get
those oars in the water out of the water
exactly at the same time all eight
people and so the one of the ways you do
that is the person who's the back of the
boat the stern of the boat
they're called the stroke they set the
stroke rate that was the position I rode
and what I learned about myself was I
was not so much interested in beating
another boat as I was in not letting
down my team they couldn't row stronger
or harder or faster than I rode so I was
gonna have to do everything I could to
make sure my team goal of beating that
other boat was achieved so I knew that I
was probably best in a career where I
was focused on team goals rather than
say as a salesperson with individual
Commission goals or whatever the other
thing I learned in that situation was
the novice coach would tell people row
exactly like Melinda
she's rowing perfectly do it just like
her everybody row like Melinda I would
have killed myself for that guy to try
and live up to that phrase the varsity
coach on the other hand would say things
like you all row for you roll like
a bunch of girls you'll never win
anything and surprisingly that actually
motivated some of the women they're like
I'll show him like show him what he's a
jerk I don't do that so I learned that
I'm probably the kind of leader I want
to be is to focus on the positive and
lift people up rather than whatever you
call that so pay attention be
introspective in every learning
situation and take every kind of test
you can take I mean there are there's
myers-briggs there's strength finders
there's what's your superpower and the
point is to look at them
not so much believe every one of them
but see what resonates with you when you
hear the feedback does that sound right
to you and what does are there themes
there on strength finders I think three
of them said I should run startup so
good I am and so really do that work as
I said you may not always want to take
them at face value
my stepdaughter Elizabeth who's here who
has having tremendous success in her
career when she was graduating from high
school they gave you one of those career
tests were you a hundred things and are
you gonna be a florist or doctor or
whatever we all thought oh that would be
fun let's do that test together the the
answer for me turned out to be a
number-one job for me was migrant farm
laborer my mother who's here was so
proud to hear that after after I'd gone
through an MBA program so anyway do as
much testing learning as you possibly
can and then once you start to develop
hypotheses about what you think you know
about yourself start to pilot that when
I took one of my pilot's was when I
turned 25 I realized you know I've been
given a lot of gifts in my life I'm
healthy I have a great family I'm
relatively smart I was raised Catholic
which told me that all these gifts were
given to me so that I could help make
the world a better place here I was 25
and not only had I not made the world a
better place yet I hadn't even started
trying so I decided at that point hey I
think I'm gonna go to law school so I
can do public interest law so I took the
law the L SAT did relatively well on
that applied to law school did
relatively well there and has that got
closer and closer to the day I was going
to attend law school I really it I knew
myself well enough that this probably
wasn't going to be what I needed to do
so I thought why don't I just pick up
and move to Washington DC and see if I
need a law degree so that's what I did I
picked up moved across country
I had no
no place to live no friends no family
there but it all worked out and Alice I
was there I ran into Bob Noyce Intel and
I was explaining to him what I was
trying to do and he said you should go
into manufacturing
we need bright minds in manufacturing
manufacturing that's processes systems I
like that it's low paid not glamorous
exactly what I'm looking for so I moved
back to the Bay Area went to work at a
manufacturing organization while I
applied to business school so that I
could learn more about my craft and
study operations when I came out of
Business School another little test they
had or a little and they listed 18
things to prioritize in terms of what
kind of career the first job you wanted
and the top three things for me was I
wanted manufacturing and operations in
the San Francisco Bay Area in the life
sciences little did I know there
probably only three country companies at
the time I could have worked out but I
found one and when I went to interview
what I really was trying to optimize on
was finding a good mentor I know a lot
of you are coming out of school and
you're thinking maybe you want to
optimize on salary or title the thing is
you're never going to need less money
than you need right now as time goes on
you will start to acquire things you'll
get a car you'll get a house you'll get
a family it will only increase your
expenses so right now is do when you can
most afford to invest in yourself and
put yourself in a learning situation and
I basically apprenticed for eight years
in that manufacturing organization and
again that's what gave me the confidence
to go ahead and start the first company
but it doesn't always have to happen in
a business setting a few years ago I was
the chair of the board of the Save the
Redwoods League and the way the board
meetings were run was they'd send out a
board book ahead of time you'd read
through it and then you'd show up at the
board me
and they'd each staff member would stand
up and basically tell you what they told
you in the board book and I thought oh
this is kind of a waste of time I
thought really the reason why you're in
a room together is so you can have a
conversation which is why we're gonna
have a Q&A at the end here not to have
somebody just give you static
information so I I changed the program
and I said look we're gonna send out the
board book we're gonna assume you've
read it and we're not going to discuss
it unless you have questions and we're
going to have conversations about things
we need to have conversations about so I
was able to pilot that idea in a
non-profit and bring it to my work in my
startups so how to get this foundational
knowledge of self knowledge of craft you
want to take every test you can you want
to pay attention you want to do the hard
work and you want to pilot things okay
so now you have this confidence how do
you keep it one of my favorite phrases
is get out before you get cranky when
you're in a situation if you know
yourself really well and you know your
craft you can tell when a situation
probably isn't right for you anymore
when most people when they choose to
move on to their next job they're saying
okay I'm gonna go from this job I'm
gonna go to the next level job so
manager to director or whatever if
you're cranky and it's starting to chip
away at your confidence most likely
you're gonna say I'm a product manager I
just want to be a product manager in
another company so you're gonna make a
lateral move worse is if you let it go
on too long you're gonna get so cranky
that you're gonna say I just got to get
out of here
you might even take a job that's lower
just to get out when I was working at
the large company we were acquired by an
even larger company so I went from being
two layers from the top to 13 layers
somebody in Sweden and somebody in
Europe cycle time for decision-making
went from three days to three months
four months and I realized
I needed to move the needle I needed to
come to work and move the needle and I
can no longer if I work nights and
weekends it would not make a difference
I would not move the needle and they
didn't really need somebody like me with
a biased toward action anymore they
needed people who could do their job
9:00 to 5:00 and so I knew I needed to
get out so what I did was I did a
personal burn chart cache burn chart I
said okay here's how much money I have
here's what my burn rate is here's when
I cross the axis Tober here's why I've
got my job September so I knew I made a
decision to get out the most common
reason people stay in a situation they
tell me I can't afford to leave my job
I've done what I call the cranky math so
if you are staying in a job you're
probably not doing a great job right so
you're gonna get below average raises
below average performance bonuses over
time but if you leave in time while you
still have confidence to do the next
step up say it's a 10% you're gonna
start to go like this so let's say you
made $100,000 a year if you could find a
way beg borrow steal $50,000 actually
take you for a year of looking for your
next job so you've borrowed the $50,000
it took it you got out quickly so you
had the confidence to go for the next
level job you're just already making
more salary and you know bonuses and
raises are based on salary so there's a
compounding effect so I did the math of
an average raise an average bonus in
this trajectory from $100,000 person 3
years you've paid off that 50k not only
have you paid it off you've probably
enjoyed those 3 years and you're on a
better trajectory so get out before you
get cranky that's how you keep yourself
from chipping away at your confidence so
you need confidence to start a company
you need confidence to persevere in a
company you need confidence to make the
hard decisions to hear others the way to
build it is to listen pay attention be
introspective put yourself in learning
situations particularly early on and
then get out before you get cranky if
you do all that and you build that gut
level foundational knowing yourself
knowing your craft that level of
confidence my hope for you is that you
can go out into the world and have a
positive impact with all that you've
learned so that's my formal remarks and
I'm happy to take questions at this
point
[Applause]
I've stumped the crowd
yes what are some things that you did
besides being on the crew team yeah so
the question is what did I do in school
to help build my confidence I I would
say basically it was mainly that and
paying attention to whatever
organization you're in whatever things
you're doing is paying attention and
learning yourself so that you could then
really know when you're trying to make
the decision of what to do next you
understand yourself well enough to be
able to make the right decision so
that's the best thing you can do in this
order and then try a lot of clubs or try
reach for leadership positions put
yourself in positions that where you can
learn a lot more about yourself way in
the back Richard have you found that
certain degrees of education are
necessary to reach different levels in
entrepreneurship particularly in biotech
have I found that certain degrees are
necessary to excel
particularly in biotech so I have an
undergraduate business degree which I
thought of as applied math because when
I was applying to college my brother
who's also here who's a PhD biochemist I
was interested in either biology or math
and he said you know if you do biology
you have to do ochem you don't want to
do Oakham - you said no I don't want it
- okay so I did business undergrad as
applied math so then I swear I would
never get another business degree I
thought it ended up being you know
people join the clubs just to get good
jobs and it was very uninteresting so I
swore I would never go back for an MBA
but when I decided operations then I
went back for that so now I have two
business degrees but I'm in a technical
field scientific that has been in every
review I've ever gotten the only thing
that's going to stand in your way
you don't have a technical undergraduate
degree so I always have to prove to
people that I can come up that learning
curve so I would say if you want to be
in a technical technical company
technical startup have some technical
street cred instead of always having to
prove that you actually do understand
what parallel which was high-throughput
sequencing and snip discovery I mean
most people don't even know what that
means and that's just the definition in
the company so I I would say at least
have some technical grounding of some
kind about building tank teams besides
looking at a resume when you interview
someone what do you ask them so for a
startup I tell people that the
characteristic above all the other ones
you look at is initiative I say tell me
about a time you looked around you and
whatever you were doing and you said
that's something we need to do so in a
startup nothing set up right you have to
set everything up from the beginning so
even if it was as they looked at they
were in a lab they saw that the
inventory of the reagents and the
refrigerators was always a mess they
said hey I think we need to have some
inventory control even if it's just a
sheet on the refrigerator and they tell
me and walk me through how they came up
with the idea and how they got it all
the way across the line
so initiative is the number one thing
I'm looking for in a start-up Korea
successfully they are still challenges
like this thank you saying yeah so the
question is and it's his words that my
career is successful I think the jury's
still out but are there challenges I
still face sure I mean bill and I
started this company because we thought
it was so challenging and so complex it
would take everything we had ever
learned but it would be worth it if we
are able to do what we say we're gonna
do so this this is not
you know walk in the park there's not
gonna be a walk in the park for me the
major thing in this company is we have
as I said these four very different
programs and how are we going to keep
people talking together actually Maurice
and Mike were great about talking about
how do we do this and Julia and Mike
came up with this we're called octave
which is a you know musical term they
call it Orchestra so every other week we
have an orchestra meeting where we see
how we can work in concert and we talk
about whatever is doing so we're trying
to so for us that's the biggest
challenge right now how do as we scale
how do we keep connected yes okay so
this is kind of a long question but you
mentioned at the beginning that you got
it reading it so that's really in New
York and then you got connected to
Mustafa who is the CEO of alumina which
i think is very cool and then you got in
touch with the Stanford genome lab which
became to my understanding one of your
first startups so did you know you
wanted to get into entrepreneurship but
at this point was it hard to make the
jump from your regular job to becoming
an entrepreneur and also with this
before or after your MBA yes so I I got
my MBA I went to this company worked
there for eight years it was acquired by
a larger company she wants to know kind
of how I made this leap into
entrepreneurship and how I knew yeah so
so so here I am we were acquired by this
large company and I'm thinking I I need
to go back to small I like to build
things I mean even when I was a child my
favorite toys were Legos building blocks
you know it wasn't Barbies it was things
I could build with so I know I like to
do that so I was talking to a friend
from business school and he said you
know you got to quit your job to be able
to look for a start-up I said oh okay
gotta quit my job and it was right I
mean I even tried to talk to a recruiter
at one point I ended up having to sit in
my car at lunchtime I mean it was it was
just too hard to do that and so that's
why I took that leap I did my cash burn
chart and I went out to do it so this
was all post MBA
but yeah I knew that I wanted to go back
to building something up your self
analysis introspection you saw your
strengths and you play to those friends
also identify your weaknesses like
suppose it's your building right the
question is I've done a lot of
introspection I know my strengths I've
built on my strengths did I ever focus
on my weaknesses and take proactive
steps on that when I I met and married
somebody who lived 3,000 miles away my
husband was a detective with the NYPD so
he couldn't tell him to commute so I had
to move there when I moved there I had
no idea what I would do what I ended up
doing was this entrepreneur-in-residence
job which really was about strategy and
funding which actually was not what I
had done before it was basically all the
things I had not done before so I did
put myself in a completely new situation
and built on those strengths and so
what's wonderful for me is now when I
came to octave when bill and I started
it I needed to use all of that so I
don't know that I went out of my way to
work on my weaknesses but I did jump
into a situation that created that that
need
so it sounds like you recently moved to
the Bay Area your mid-level career is
that what you mean or okay and so you're
looking for somebody you're not starting
your career but you're looking how do
you find a mentor - so I think in that
case you just continue to network and go
to things and then coaching most
everybody I know gets some kind of
coaching and they their job is to help
you figure that next move and how to
move up so I actually just signed up for
a an executive coach in the last few
days
Oh IRA and you already asked a question
you've asked a person okay do you think
your experience doing growing in college
helped reshape you leaders yes so how do
I think that my experience on the crew
team at Cal helped shape my me as a
leader absolutely in that it taught me a
lot about myself I also actually taught
rowing for 22 years off and on up in San
Francisco Bay and actually having to
teach adults how to not flip into the
water so they have a lot of fear how to
give them the information I had to think
about how to tell them the same thing
but I had to come up with two or three
different ways to explain it because
everybody learns differently so that was
pretty important and how I became a
leader the other thing about being on
the crew team people give you a
ridiculous halo effect
I tell people particularly male VCS that
I was on the crew team and all of a
sudden oh you're so great you're so
disciplined and everything I'm like okay
okay great and it so I tell everybody if
you've already been on the crew team
even for one year make sure it's on your
resume yes
yeah thanks for sharing your story and a
lot of these lessons I wanted to go back
to the part of your journey where you
mentioned you moved up you picked up and
moved over to DC you didn't know what
you were doing you don't know anyone and
you kind of happenstance on this career
changing individual from Intel that
brought you back over here could you
elaborate on that a little bit more and
maybe what type of confidence it took to
seek out this individual and to like
listen to that piece of advice when I'm
sure you are getting so many different
perspectives at a time so the question
was how did I have the confidence to
move to Washington DC and then how did I
know to listen to the mentor to Bob
Noyce when he gave me the advice the
confidence to pick up and move you know
I I knew that I really couldn't fail
like give it a try if it works great if
it doesn't come back I hadn't really
failed at much at that point
mainly because for me I wasn't trying to
achieve like I've never had a five-year
plan I've never said I'm gonna be a
such-and-such by the time I'm 40 I've
always chosen my jobs on what do I think
I will enjoy and do well so it makes it
easier to kind of pick up and move why
did I listen to him I think it's the
same kind of thing where I had a gut
instinct of who I was and when he
suggested that it landed well it's like
yeah that sounds good he also put it as
you know rebuild America's manufacturing
base you know creating jobs for people I
truly believe that if people have good
jobs that make them feel good about what
they've done all day I think a lot of
the world's problems would go away
because everybody getting to spend time
doing something valuable so I think
that's it I knew enough about myself
when I heard that advice it sounded
right yes
my question to you is with regard to the
IPRA of mentioned that ah you know so
there are certain things that you don't
know about you learned on the way and
you know you kind of navigate your way
through uncharted territory
so having recently ship is currently
starting out in in my career what what
is it that you have to say when it comes
to you know starting out towards
starting out in your career how should
one go about you know doing that should
education the aspect that you know I
should be taking into consideration or
should should I probably contact work
out and like meet a bunch of people and
then gradually stumble into something
that I would be interested so you're
trying to figure out how to approach
your career should you network to get
education don't know your specific thing
but I would you've got to have some
ideas
so either talk to a lot of people about
them and see if what you're thinking you
might want to do they agree with you or
put yourself in learning situations or
both but you've got to have some ideas
about what you want to do so start start
and learn and iterate your engineers you
know relating to what you said about
introspection and finding your strengths
how do you revolve if you're in a
situation say where your strengths don't
really align with what you feel
passionate about or what you would like
to get strong on the things you want to
do and so the placement
sorry was you know what if you're good
at this and you want to do this get good
at this
you know learn put yourself in the suit
I mean you got a start right and if you
don't do that then you've told yourself
I can't get good at this and until
you've tried you don't know that so I'd
give it a shot I'm so nervous right now
basically you should get a technical
some kind of a technical background if
you want to do technical naturally you
have overcome certain challenges with
you mentioned so what was something
focused on to welcome these challenges
of not having a tech background I just
so how did I succeed in a technical
field without having a technical degree
I worked really hard and I did a good
job and success you know people are
willing to bet on you if you've shown
that you can do it before my father says
I did too steep learning curves so I try
and learn a lot very quickly and then I
probably spoke with confidence and
people believed I could do what I said I
could do whether or not I could or not I
don't know but I seem to believe I could
ya know do I feel fulfilled in my life
oh this navel-gazing about introspection
yeah I do actually
I feel pretty pretty I'm doing what I
know I'm supposed to be doing and I know
it's using everything I need to to
accomplish it and that makes me feel
fulfilled if I can bring everything to
it
I also the one thing that was missing I
talked about how you can move some
decisions out I didn't get married till
later in life so that was something that
was missing but I picked that up and
that's going pretty well so yeah so I'm
[Laughter]
anybody else has one personal question
okay you mentioned that early in your
career you optimized to find good
mentorship instead of a high salary
could you speak a bit more about what
you yeah so the question was how did I
identify a good mentor it's good right
yeah and during the interview process
the questions he asked me and what he
was trying to do in the organization the
way he explained it he was explaining
things to me all the way along and and
he liked to talk about that so that in
and of itself but also knowing that he
knew how to do it well in fact when I
was coming out of business school and I
knew I wanted to do operations I thought
in a manufacturing organization what's a
core competence and if you're starting a
company you might think about this
what's a core competence I really need
to have and for manufacturing its
inventory turns
so I actually considered going to work
for a grocery store for a couple of
years a grocery chain so that I could
learn how to do inventory turns really
well who does that really well right and
so that doesn't talk to a mentorship but
that talks about finding somebody who
really does it the best and putting
yourself so if there's a company that
something about it does it the best
maybe you want to go work there and take
that to the company you want to start
one more question okay way in the back
often passes or not do it like outcomes
and data right so is there some point in
time if future you guys do open source
tenido like make how it happens for guts
that are big so something on the similar
length of the data you have in the
pipeline to open source so I couldn't
quite hear everything you said you're
asking me if octave is going to open its
data for open source work
so what we
just thought about as a company is we're
going to innovate on the things we need
to innovate on and then we're going to
partner and collaborate on the things
that we don't need to so I can see a
point where what we're bringing is the
service and the data can be greater if
we work with other so I don't know where
that business model will be at that
point but I wouldn't rule that out all
right
[Applause]